Lauren is with us in Chicago hey Lauren
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how do
you thanks for having me sure a longtime
listener thank you and you've helped me
a lot over the past year so I appreciate
you I wish I was calling with a
different question but this is the
question I have it's sort of a moral and
financial conflict if you will and I
would appreciate your feedback my
ex-husband he had the terminal illness
we have two two children and they're 11
and 14 we have a very we don't
unfortunately have a good relationship
we've had a very rural court a lot and
things like that but overall this is
just the status right now so she created
an estate plan and a trust for the kids
to cover their expenses he claims it
will cover everything whatever they can
want their weddings college and that
they both be paid out at about I think
the age of 30 maybe a million dollars
each somewhere around there
her divorce decree we have an obligation
to hold a life insurance policy for each
other with the children the children
listed as beneficiaries and then the
other parent as a trustee my ex is
stating to me that he will not allow for
me to have what he considers a financial
windfall or benefit from his death in
any way and he wants me to sign away my
rights to the $250,000 life-insurance
policy and in return he is offering to
pay me a monthly stipend until the
children are 18 he states if I do not
agree that he will bury all of this
money that they would otherwise inherit
and has what he called a poison pill or
something in his plan and the kids will
not see any of it at any time I just
want to know morally what you thought
about this at first you know what a
mother should do in this kind of
situation
I don't do extortion yeah and
I'm really sorry this gentleman is sick
but what you've described to me is sick
and evil yes mm-hmm
and so I would look at him and say you
will abide by the divorce decree and I
will be staying on this if you choose to
penalize your own children that does not
make a statement about me that makes a
statement about you and what kind of man
you are and what kind of legacy you're
going to leave mm-hmm I think he's
bluffing yeah
he has manipulated you for years
as a master manipulator mm-hmm he's a
bully and is an extortionist am I wrong
no you're not this is not the first time
you have experienced this in motion with
this man while married to him and post
divorce as well right this is not the
first time on stantly polls this kind of
crap yes yeah and he doesn't follow
sorry well I usually give in somewhat
and so I only worry about the long-term
effects I usually meet I usually give
too much honestly I give in too much and
you know at this point I've moved on
with my life we've been divorced 10
years old children how do you make a
year my husband and I make about 275
okay so you don't needing this money and
your kids will be fine your kids will be
fine
hey well yeah now I would I would tell
him too that I'm really sorry you're
sick but what you're proposing to me is
you know is in violation of our
agreement and so we will we will be
sticking with the agreement you will be
sending me you'll be leaving me on the
policy if you do not immediately I will
have the court intervene and and you're
not leaving money to your kids is not a
statement about me it's a statement
about you so what legacy do you want to
believe how do you want your children
and therefore your grandchildren to
were you and it's up to you how you want
to act I can't control if you want to be
evil and misbehave that's up to you but
that's how you're going to be remembered
and then you can decide what you want to
do and if you want to leave the kids
nothing it'll be okay we'll take care of
them right and so you think morally if
they did ultimately end up with nothing
because obviously this is a very dark
you know that would be hold everything
it's not my it's his fault it's not
yours
mm-hmm that's his fault
morally morally right if he chooses to
not leave his children money as a
vindictive act against his ex-wife
because she would not cave to his
manipulation that is evil that's evil
right okay and you know I think it is
high time for your mental health sake
that used to end up and you just say you
know I'm just not gonna play right I'm
not I'm not gonna be you do what you
want to do but I I do not I want you to
hear loud and clear that you have done
nothing wrong right he may or may not do
something wrong but I would shout him
out I would just say how do you want to
be remembered yeah well I did during
this we met and had a small short
conversation about it and he said that
he just does not care and he will not
die having me benefit in any way I don't
know okay that's fine if you want to be
remembered as a complete twerp who's
evil and misplaced his priorities
Invicta and vindictiveness replace the
vindictiveness over the care of your
children then you want that to be your
legacy that's fine you you just decided
that but it's not up to me it's up to
you because no I'm not caving right time
to stick in this here
I can't beliee
[Applause]
you know think how I would be so mad at
someone that I would punish my children
to keep them from
something I just can't imagine that I
would get there I mean this guy it's got
real issues and it's sad that he's
terminal I'm so sorry because he well
what a horrible thing but no I you do
what you want to do you ask my opinion
I don't do extortion and so it's do your
worst
you know I'm gonna do what I'm going to
do and then you have to decide what
you're gonna do but I'm not going to be
told what to do because you threatened
me that's extortion and never I matter
of fact I have a real tendency to not do
things that are wise sometimes just to
not be threatened into something it's
kind of a hillbilly thing I think kind
of redneck thing just you know just
because you told me that means I'll
never do it you know that thing
[Music]